[Música]
como ustedes saben
en los aeropuertos ocurren cosas raras
no sé ustedes a mí sí a veces cuando
estoy decidido como hombre de negocios y
en otras ocasiones cuando trato de pasar
desapercibido como hoy como turista en
algún aeropuerto
los aeropuertos tienen tiene un no sé
qué decía un tango los aeropuertos
tienen nos brindan la oportunidad de
analizar el zoológico de la humanidad
yo lo veo como una torre de babel plana
donde se conjugan razas lenguas culturas
en los aeropuertos pasó aproximadamente
90 días del año y se darán cuenta de que
para una persona de negocios el tiempo
solo y trato de aprovecharlo les voy a
contar ahora alguna de las situaciones
que ocurren de las primeras estoy
sentado leyendo un libro o escuchando
música y a veces una persona se acerque
al esto que alumbró uno y le dice usted
don pedro si le digo le puedo hacer una
pregunta y ahí comienzan los
sentimientos encontrados porque una
pregunta gratuita hagamos la respuesta
gratuita y ustedes comprenderán que el
que nos altura no come
entonces
por el bien de la humanidad siempre digo
por amor al arte les daba una respuesta
a ciertas preguntas de algunas con más
extensión algunas con menos de intención
para que ustedes tengan idea de las
cuatro preguntas que más me hacen es
cómo consigo trabajo
como retengo mi empleo si es que tiene
trabajo
como consigo clientes y como tengo
clientes cuatro preguntas
entonces hace años atrás descubrí que
para no ahondar demasiado resumía mi
respuesta a tenés que adquirir más
conocimientos tenéis que estudiar más
tenéis que saber más porque si conoces
más que otras personas te van a elegir
para un trabajo y si conoces más que tus
competidores los clientes te van a
elegir
esa respuesta
hasta hace 10 años atrás era válida pero
ya no déjenme explicarles el siglo 19
fue llamado el siglo de la
industrialización que significaba que
todo aquello que era a la fuerza se
volvió marginal
el siglo 20 se lo llamó el siglo del
vanguardismo porque muchas disciplinas
como la medicina el transporte la
comunicación gracias a la tecnología
según despegue de tremendo
pero llega el siglo 21 siglo que estamos
viviendo y alguien lo bautiza como el
siglo del conocimiento
a mi entender es un error
quizás porque se basaron en una premisa
un poco peligrosa de que era que la
persona que tenía conocimiento a
diferencia de otros tenía el poder o sea
aquella persona que conocía más aquella
empresa que sabía más aquella industria
que sabía más tenía mejor performance
que las demás era un poco como no si se
recuerdan si man yo tengo el poder veo
que era que no tienen ni idea
les voy ahora le voy a dar otra versión
la media me dame dame dame el poder
dame dame dame dame dame el power
molotov
ya lo entendieron bien
se decía que si una persona tenía
conocimiento tenía el poder error error
y hoy inocentada hoy no es el siglo del
conocimiento les explico por qué
ya en el año 2015 se especulaba que de
los 7 mil 500 millones de personas que
formamos este planeta ya teníamos un
celular o un móvil
nunca la historia o la humanidad ningún
medio estuvo tan al alcance de la
población más allá de lo del nivel
socioeconómico más allá de las culturas
regiones tecnologías entonces este
aparato que hoy tenemos en las manos que
se dice nos acerca de los que están
lejos
y nos aleja de lo que estamos cerca es
tremendo porque el conocimiento está ahí
les voy a dar algunos ejemplos el
primero si en el intermedio ingresan al
google y colocan cursos gratis en
español les aparecen 60 millones de
resultados
es decir lugares donde ingreso y accedo
al curso gratis de que autoayuda
computadora excel matemática curso de
cerámica lo que quieran pero si coloco
cursos gratis en inglés
los resultados son las 600 millones de
lugares
y se me pasó a youtube que se ha
convertido en el tutor por eso hoy se
habla de un mundo sin adultos cuando
antes no sabíamos algo a quien le
consulta amor papá mamá abuelos maestros
hoy los muchachos le consultan a
wikipedia siri google bueno ya youtube
porque en youtube tiene algo increíble
usted tiene cursos gratis de que es que
quiere saber a tocar un gel el curso de
la persona que quiera saber inglés
porque me dicen como inglés pero espero
que el curso inglés gratis gratis pero
no son sólo los open english inclusiva
al ingresar los únicos los únicos que
dan cursos de inglés
esos son poniendo y estos cursos son
gratis cada uno dice son gratis desde
ese medio es trucho no porque gratis
para lo que no saben es que estos cursos
gratis acceden millones de personas en
todo el mundo entonces y el dinero no es
del nuestro
es el de los anunciantes que colocan su
marca para que la vean millones de
personas
y en youtube se encuentra usted cómo
armar una bomba como y gracias al doctor
lozano como domesticaron suegras
difíciles
curso ok entonces se llega a una
conclusión
hoy ser burro en una decisión
porque el conocimiento está allí y ahí
viene la pregunta
si todos tenemos acceso al conocimiento
ahora dónde está la diferencia para
conseguir el pleno para retener empleo
para conseguir clientes para retener
clientes
y ahí viene la segunda parte de los
aeropuertos dónde
es un campo de experimentación y de
descubrimiento fantástico al pasar
muchas horas y cuando leía llega un
poquito a una página 14 15 a bs menos
uno se cansa y cuando escucha música si
está buena se queda dormido no se puede
perder un avión entonces dije tengo que
estar atento a lo que ocurre aquí lo
primero que hice fue un ejercicio que
será el consejo que es imaginar qué
hacen las personas en el aeropuerto
entonces yo me sentaba y miraba y veía
una madre así triste acongojada y mi
cabeza decía seguro que esta mujer se
está yendo a trabajar a otro país 5 o 6
años y está triste porque deje a sus
hijos a sus parejas hacia toda la
película después veía a un ejecutivo así
con su maleta mirando el horizonte y
decía diseñando debe estar pensando el
negocio que va a ser cómo le va a
cambiar la vida su rostro las tapas de
las revistas de negocios y después
también veía las parejas que entran de
la mano sin rápido mirando
a todos lados dice estos son amantes
confirmado
[Música]
y ahí dije tengo que hacer algo más
lo primero que hice fue comenzar a
fotografiar gente que chateaba que llegó
sin familias enteras
parejas jóvenes todo chateando chateando
y después diciendo no no no porque
alguna cámara va a sacar con su sistema
de inteligencia que yo estuve en
aeropuerto es un mes atrás sacando fotos
garrapata pensando que soy talibán o
terrorista o algo parecido y el
miércoles qué más puede hacer
y es que lo que le vengo a contar
hace 10 años
descubrí algo
fabuloso
me puse cerca de la puerta de
migraciones
y cuando se abría
aparecían las parejas de parejas
como es
se abre la puerta y aparece un mujerón
así miércoles una artista de cine así de
la mano consumo obstruido con supuesta y
móvil
pero es la bella y la bestia o sea no
broma gente que la naturaleza no la
favoreció y ahí uno las tiene que ver
porque todo el aeropuerto se da vuelta o
baja de cierto y quiero yo miraba y hata
que las mujeres no se rían
porque también es el caso contrario
se abre la puerta aparece un gladiador
un defensor de fútbol de la selección de
islandia y
y su bruja de la mano
entonces como a mí me interesa más
conocer qué pasaba con los hombres por
la naturaleza humana
decía mente rápida no seguro que los
fríos son millones los
seguro que el freno millonario y después
se puso a pensar puede haber tanto frío
millonario
y la otra si los feos o millonario y
portillo
esa fue la que más me preocupó porque
ese millonario
entonces hice lo que haría cualquier en
persona que le interesa conocerla
natural de esa realidad que es esperaba
que las parejas se sienten en el snack
en el restaurante entonces yo empezaba
un lento caminar
y
me sentaba en la mesa de al lado
espalda espalda con el monstruito ahí
me dicen para que para escuchar cómo
funciona la cosa porque tiene que haber
un misterio ahí decía es imposible que
todos los juegos y millonarios
escuchen lo que descubrí
en 10 años
quizás más de 300 parejas
nunca pero nunca conocía el nombre de la
persona
porque no se llaman por el nombre
se dice mi amor
mi rey
mi reina
me caramelito al monstruo de delito
en el colegio claro investigada puede
ser hasta está ocurriendo algo que es lo
único
entonces que hice observar más
me puse a observar muy atento lo que
ocurría desde el principio y me daba
cuenta de que el monstruito cuando
llegara a la mesa él le corría la silla
a la pareja para que se siente cosa con
los caballeros parece un olvidado de que
eso existe es un hermoso gesto
cuando ella se sentaba a ver el menú ahí
el menú él ya le decía mi amor no es que
elija nada
ya le pedí su capuchino latte con una
cucharada de stevia y sus sándwiches
mixtos caliente con un toquecito de
mostaza con miel
y dije acá esto aquí hay que aprenderlo
y comenzaron a aparecer las curiosidades
cuando un día ya
es mucho que le dice me espera mi amor
un momento que ya vengo igual se invitó
a basta basta hermoso se acerca el mozo
y quedó el hijo digo este nieto capaz
del cumpleaños una mujer y ha preparado
que se rompa el techo keyhan mariachi
con guitarra dispara caídas porque ya
hay algo con todas esas cosas que
miércoles lo que más podía hacer y me
dio una tremenda sorpresa porque al rato
bien hermoso con esa cara de hermoso
cómplice que sólo los mossos tienen dos
cuando venían una tasa de fe se acerca y
le dicen señora esta taza de café se la
dedica a su esposo
ya mi cuello era
porque el miércoles tenías la planta de
café y ella me dice
y ella le dice mi amor es la primera vez
que me sirven un café con la inicial de
mi nombre en cacao encima de la crema
después de eso hasta yo me quería casar
con este desgraciado
miércoles
entonces qué conclusión d
de que usted sea es una persona
y quizás la belleza no la ha favorecido
si quizás usted tiene una empresa donde
no tiene el mejor producto
si quizás es una industria donde no
tiene el mejor servicio intenté cambiar
el chip de una relación comercial a una
conexión emocional
conexión emocional es la mejor
traducción de carisma que he encontrado
y puedo contar que a mí me pasó me pasó
porque al aprender eso dije intentaré
retener a mis clientes o buscar clientes
bajo la misma fórmula y que dije cada
vez que visita alguien cada vez que
reciba a alguien voy a intentar más allá
del número una negociación la propuesta
fría establecer una conexión emocional y
ahí el consejo que les vi
lamentablemente cuando se es y
positivamente es cultura porque en una
ocasión me dijeron pero te conseguimos
una reunión con un cliente es sumamente
importante leo quienes le llaman el
señor media hora si le digo media hora
porque por este tipo te atiende media
hora
mi presentación dura unos 45 minutos y
la comprimir y les confieso que no me
sentía seguro con la presentación por
una presentación de 45 es como que a uno
le corten la pierna y a la misma altura
no y me toca ir a la reunión con el
señor media hora y ahí entendí por qué
le enseñan ción y ahora porque entré me
dijo buenos días señor que ahora tiene
media hora para presentar
yo dije cuánta presión y hay ocurrió lo
que steve jobs en una de sus últimas
conferencias llama los puntos se
conectan
cuando usted tiene un conocimiento
determinado en otra situación
media hora después o medio siglo después
usted la conecta y la aprovecha en el
caso de steve jobs era porque mientras
él estudiaba negocios hizo un curso de
caligrafía imagínense la escuela de
negocio curso de caligrafía nada que ver
pero después que hizo cuando creó a todo
apro nació con las mejores fondos o
tipografías del mundo miren como los
puntos se conectan bueno ya mí me pasó
porque cuando me estaba por sentar y
ella calculé miércoles perdido 25
segundos voy a preguntar se pierde un
minuto de algo
y detrás de la persona había un escudo
de madera de familia esto que tienen
todas las cosas los perendengues y no
y circula familia y mejor
me jugué por ese verbo intentar buscar
una conexión emocional le pregunto es el
escudero mi familia de su familia
el hombre se da vuelta con esas caras
también de orgullo y dice sí y le dije y
usted sabe lo que significa
no
y yo le dije y yo sí
media hora le expliqué el escudo
[Música]
y de ahora hablamos de negocios
hoy en día es uno de mis clientes ahora
dónde viene lo bonito les conté que
steve jobs hizo un curso de caligrafía
por eso más más y mientras escuchando
ascendente mensajes
yo me escapaba mucho del colegio en los
últimos dos años
mucho o sea pero no era por irme con mis
amigos porque porque me aburría
la verdad me aburría y medicina donde se
lleva pedro a las bibliotecas
y en las bibliotecas mejorar mi sándwich
mi refresco y le tenía que echar cinco o
seis horas leyendo a partir del único
lugar donde nadie me iba a ver cómo les
encontró una biblioteca
y que hacían al principio comenzar a
leer los libros de mi interés pero
después comencé a leer siderúrgica
carpintería metalúrgica deporte brujería
y en cuestión esto heráldica
heráldica es el alta de los escudos
y me acuerdo de ese libro me llamó la
atención porque yo soy muy visual y
estaba lleno de colores dorados entonces
aprendí en esas seis horas de escape del
colegio algo que me sirvió
40 años después
los puntos se conectan
entonces dónde viene lo interesante
hoy no es el siglo del conocimiento
hoy es el siglo del relacionamiento
porque el conocimiento lo tenemos todo
pero la capacidad de relacionarse no
y es ahí donde usted puede establecer
una diferencia
sobre eso cuando vi esta situación del
café con la inicial
ese día yo decidí ser una bestia
la bella y la bestia'
tenía mi rol muy claro que era quizás
alguna desventaja
e intentar buscar una conexión emocional
porque reitero el conocimiento es de
todos
así que
yo le sugiero
les pido les aconsejo que a partir de
hoy si quieren conseguir trabajo retener
trabajo conseguir clientes buscar
clientes se conviertan en las bestias
más bellas de este mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]